[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا من اخبارنا
الاخرى بعد جبهه الخلاص الوطني في تونس
الى قيام حكومه انقاذ وطنيه قادره على
التصدي للازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في
البلاد وفق نص بيان الجبهه
يشي
ل الناليات الاستعراضيه وفق تعبيرها
الرئيس
سعيد يوعز من جهه للحكومه لرفع الاسعار ثم
يصرح بضروره عدم المس بالقدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين
كما تهمت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه سلطات
الامنيه والمحليه بولايه سيدي بوزيد
بممارسه ضغوط لمنع اجتماع عام للجبهه كان
مقررا تنظيمه يوم غدا الاحد بمنطقه الرقاب
في اطار تحركاتها المناهضه للرئيس قيس
سعيد
عامه بمدينه رجاب
كلفها ذلك ما كلفها حسب وصفها
مكاسب ثوره في حريه التعبير والاستماع
وتظاهر السلمي داعيه كافه القوه الوطنيه
الى تضامن معها دفاعا عن الحريه حسب
البيان